that's the thing about these countries I
was just in England Scotland Ireland
Australia no black people and I know
what you're thinking
no no you need black people you need
black people to keep the whites in check
the last thing you want is a whole
island of whites that think they're the
coolest people on Earth it's a disaster
that's how you end up with Conor
McGregor walking around
like it's like shut up dude the foreign
whites are out of
control American whites we're humble
we know we're not the coolest guys
around for real though there's a reason
every good NBA player that's white is
from another country the audacity to
think you could play in that League dude
the arrogance every white dude
in America saw a black kid dunk in like
8th grade and was just like oh all
right there goes that
dream we just set pic for the next four
years just box out hard as hell